Most organizations have a wide variety
of technology they use to accomplish
their task. This can include all of the
mobile devices, laptops, desktop
computers, anything that's in our
network infrastructure such as routers,
switches, or firewalls. We also have to
think about all of the fiber modules and
individual cards that we're putting into
these devices. And all of this
information needs to be tracked and
managed from one central point. Having a
centralized database with all of this
information contained in it allows us to
provide better support for all of these
different products. When the user
contacts us about a problem, we can
bring up their entire system with all of
the individual components, the make, the
model, the date it was purchased, and
any other important information that we
might need to help resolve this problem.
We can also use this database from a
financial perspective. We can create
reports showing how much money we've
spent on these technologies over the
last year. We can determine if we have a
larger spend on tablets versus laptops.
We can also run audits to make sure that
all of these devices are still being
used in the organization. And from a tax
perspective, it's useful to understand
the depreciation of all these devices.
So, it's important to know when they
were purchased and how long the
organization has held on to these
assets. And if you work for a company
and they've handed you a laptop, you
might look at the laptop and notice that
there is a tag on the laptop itself.
This is an asset tag and it usually has
the name of the organization along with
some type of QR code or barcode along
with a number that is specific to this
tag. Inside of our database, we are
associating this specific tag number
with the component that it's connected
to. So we can ask our user for the asset
number or the asset tag value and we can
bring that up on our screen and see
exactly the hardware that we're talking
about.
This centralized asset tracking system
is often referred to as a configuration
management database or CMDB.
This is not just used by the help desk
but used across the organization. This
might be used by the IT department so
that we can tie a specific asset to a
specific individual. So, if we bring up
a person's name, we can see if they've
been assigned a laptop, if they have a
mobile device, or if they're using a
tablet. Our financial department might
use this database to understand when
these devices were purchased so that
they can understand which one of these
devices are in warranty and how many of
these devices are out of warranty. This
might help them understand if they need
to allocate funds towards a maintenance
program or if they should budget for
additional technologies in the coming
year. And the licensing team might use
the information in this database to
understand how much they're spending on
individual software licenses and to get
an understanding of what the renewal
deadlines might be for these licenses
and how much money they'll need to
spend.
Every company has a different process
for requesting, purchasing, and then
deploying these different technologies.
We refer to this as the procurement life
cycle. This is effectively the process
used for purchasing this equipment and
getting it into the hands of the
enduser. This commonly starts with an
internal purchase request form that is
coming from the user. This will list out
all of the different devices this user
is requesting and it usually has
information on whether this is something
that is budgeted or not. And it might
also include a set of formal approvals
so you can see exactly who signed off on
this user receiving this equipment. The
purchasing department is responsible for
receiving these requests from the user
and then negotiating with suppliers to
find the best deal. This may not
necessarily be the provider that has the
least cost because there are number of
terms and conditions that might be
associated with this purchase. For
example, one vendor might add on an
additional year of maintenance whereas
another vendor might not provide that as
part of the cost. And once the
purchasing department has decided on a
vendor, they can send a purchase order
over to that vendor for the purchase.
The vendor then provides the products to
the end user and then commonly sends an
invoice to the purchasing department.
This is a request made by the vendor to
have the company pay for the products
that have been shipped to the user.
Usually, there is an accepted time frame
between when the invoice is received by
the purchasing department and when the
payment is made by the accounting
department. As you can see with this
process, there are a series of checks
and balances to ensure that the end user
is getting the equipment they need, that
that equipment has been verified as
something the user should be purchasing,
and we have the proper procedures in
place to receive the equipment, be
invoiced on that equipment, and then pay
the vendor for that service or that
product.